[Music]
every October 17th thousands of people
marched to the center of Buenos Aires to
celebrate the Pyrenees party and what
they see as its fight for social justice
the values of perinism are more
important than ever
movement that Privileges and gives
rights to the most vulnerable in society
we have to be on the streets demanding
inclusive politics and a government that
is not only out for the rich
on October 17 1945 thousands of people
took to the streets to demand the
release of Coronel Juan Domingo Peron
who had been detained by members of the
military
his wife Evita organized the protest the
couple became some of Argentina's most
renowned political figures and less than
a year later Peron was president
eight decades later the Pyrenees party
remains Argentina's most powerful
movement
there's big divisions within the
Pyrenees party right now the most
significant one is the rift that exists
between President Alberto Fernandez and
his vice president and former president
Christina Fernandez the kirschner those
divisions generate lots of uncertainty
about which is the way out of the
current financial and economic crisis
Fernando Aquino Works in a tourist
company in Buenos Aires he says there's
no reason for anyone to be celebrating
they're making my work difficult aside
from the economic situation I cannot
move around the city the tourists I have
to take to the airport will lose their
flight and all because these people want
to celebrate something that happened 45
years ago
Argentina is in the middle of an
economic crisis inflation is close to
seven percent a month until now the
government has been unable to find a
solution
analysts say the government right now is
focused on stabilizing the economy ahead
of next year's presidential election
the only objective right now is to not
lose votes From The Heart Of The peronis
Party The around 35 percent they have
but they cannot improve the economic
situation there's no time they don't
have the elements and they don't want to
practice open heart surgery to fix
things
the Pyrenees party is struggling to
maintain support as the economy
deteriorates
but there are millions who continue to
believe it is the way forward in spite
of their difficulties and an uncertain
future
there is